aquí en gerson los militares ucranianos
libran una feroz contraofensiva para
liberar la región que está en manos de
moscú desde que inició la invasión una
historia similar se vive a 30 kilómetros
de distancia en mykolaiv donde
bombardeos diarios han destruido gran
parte de la ciudad y las autoridades
piden asistencia internacional para
ayudar a las desesperadas tropas
el ejército de rusia es más poderoso
tienen mucha artillería y munición
nos hemos quedado sin munición de
nuestras reservas así que la ayuda de
europa y américa es muy muy importante
porque necesitamos municiones para
defender nuestro país
los depósitos de municiones y
combustible que aún quedan en ucrania
son blancos prioritarios para el
ejército ruso los ataques con misiles y
artillería alcanzaron una instalación de
almacenamiento de combustible militar en
la región de nicolás y también
destruyeron un puente hecho por los
militares ucranianos sobre el río xibi
de adán jets cerca de sa en proto pizcas
poco
la ubicación de la ciudad que conecta
con crime a gerson y la ciudad portuaria
de odessa la convierte en punto clave
para el futuro económico del país para
protegerse se levantaron barricadas pero
los civiles se debaten por sobrevivir y
dependen del apoyo humanitario para
abastecerse de alimentos y agua potable
tras una o dos veces por semana venimos
a recoger agua es imposible beber el
agua de los pozos es demasiado salada no
tenemos otra opción siempre pues antes
de la guerra mykolaiv albergaba a más de
400.000 personas ahora miles han huido y
el gobierno local pide a las personas a
abandonar la zona teniendo que la
escasez cobre más vidas que las bombas